I want to move on kind of a bonus Talk
of the table in a way because it's about
a show that is the talk of my table at
home almost every day it's the hit CBS
comedy ghosts it's about a couple Sam
and Jay who inherit a mansion but a
group of ghosts already live in the
mansion and then after an accident Sam
can see and interact with the ghost but
Jake cannot comedy ensues tonight the
show premieres a very Spirited One Hour
Christmas episode on CBS and Paramount
plus and actor Asher grodman who plays a
1990s Wall Street bro and the ghost
Trevor he found a way to message with
Jay's living sister who he's got a crush
on that's Bayla and he's having a hard
time when she shows up with another guy
very cute architect who's single here's
a preview
what's wrong Trevor it's just this whole
thing with baylo seeing her again has
brought up a lot of old feelings I
actually like her and she likes me and
now I have to watch Sam set her up with
this dweeb what does he have that I
don't a body
whoop
hmm what well
no it's crazy what say it
well we know from Hedy and Jay how a
ghost can possess a person right
yeah and Bayla did say that Eric would
do basically anything she asked oh my
God status you're saying that I possess
Eric so I can be with Bayla that's
exactly what I'm saying
exactly Asher grodman good morning hi
guys
this show brings so much joy to my
household and so many others so it's
great to meet you you brought so much
joy to me with your Halloween costumes I
hope you guys have a picture of it well
let's get right to it all right
when you saw that there it is
[Applause]
and there's no boxers you really you
went for it
my wife Katie there is of course Sam
after her head injury it makes Trevor's
dream come true right there yeah yeah
all he wants to be married to Sam he's
got a big crush on Sam you guys can have
a really good time on this show uh we do
really like each other yeah we do I I
think there's uh uh you know we were
about to shoot the pilot right before
the pandemic hit and then obviously the
world shut down and so we kind of spent
a whole year in limbo and getting to
know each other we were like on this
little life raft together and then going
to Montreal and kind of being uh our own
little community so I work with the most
fun people around uh every day I know
but Asher when you heard the premise
because I was late to the party Tony was
there from the very beginning yeah but
when you heard the premise did you say
God this sounds really good
um oh yes yes I thought the second that
I read this thing I was like this is the
best pilot I've ever read and if we
could just hit it on the air yes it it
um it was a big hit overseas it's a big
hit overseas the con the BBC concept I
think is just like once in a generation
concept truly it opens up so many
possibilities and when I read the pilot
I was like you could do anything yeah so
then when you kind of tried out for the
role or however you got it did they just
have you drop your pants right away
that's right all right no however you
got it
thank you it's going to get me in
trouble
um I uh to be honest the the uh the I
have never done a comedy before oh so
the idea that I wouldn't be wearing
pants was kind of a relief I was like
all right well if I if I screw up this
joke they can just pull to a wide shot
and I'm a dude not wearing pants and
that should take care of doing calf
exercises cat I I uh I I've never really
been a Nate's Gonna Roll his eyes I've
never really been like a late day guy
really but I would appear that you are I
know I got my childhood uh fencing oh I
think that that kind of took care you
know so I don't look completely out of
proportion now I am an appreciator of
like how much did you know about
Trevor's background because he's kind of
a jerk really but not really actually no
no no no no but but the way he's
described the way he's described he's
kind of a jerk until you get to know him
yeah until you get to know him he's one
of those Wall Street kind of kind of
guys yes yeah Wall Street Bros I you
know on the page there was such a I love
Tony until you get to dance what is on
my side
story spends a day in my pants and you
get it but go ahead
um the the the on the page there's this
really specific guy written and then
when I read it I was like I feel like if
you can just add like an element of a
puppy to this dude it there's that's a
nice juxtaposition because he thought he
was a jerk too at first no I didn't
think he was a jerk because I went I
went to college with a lot of these guys
I get it but I'm also like at their
courts like come on let's have fun yeah
he's like that first fraternity is that
he's with nine people who are like no
yeah that's not so the show will dive
into the backstory of Trevor a little
bit more but what can you tell us about
this special and the special guests that
might be coming up soon oh oh well well
first of all the hour-long concept is so
much fun because we get to as you see
Trevor is going to attempt to do what no
ghosts has ever done before so the
ending of the hour-long episode is kind
of a jaw dropper we won't give it away I
can't involving you say character yeah
but I can say you know wait you wait
till the like like a Marvel movie
yes one of Trevor's great dreams is
Gonna Come True okay I can say this
really the lovely Tara read is going to
be visiting Woodstone so you'll get a
little bit of some insight into right
what happened you know between them yes
uh there'll be a memorial for Trevor uh
they're going to find his body and his
parents are going to come to visit the
house you'll get a little more of uh the
Trevor backstory and you know and the
Trevor backstory is terrific by the way
when you one of the best episodes of TV
of the whole year according to
Entertainment Weekly was the story of
how Trevor lost his pants and ended up
dead in the process could you please
remember your pants at this time and
Tony it's funny came into my dressing
room pant list which is a wonderful
intro HR I'm being told it's time to go
uh we are out of time human resources
look at that the leg man are you
watching the hour-long ghosts ghost Miss
ghost or Hanukkah or Hanukkah okay I
like both of those tonight eight seven
Central here on CBS and on Paramount
Plus